er kümmert die erste frage an sie was
haben sie gedacht als sie diese zahl
gehört haben gestern gas umlage 2,4 19
cent pro kilowattstunde carter schlag zu
hohe belastung oder besser als gedacht
man muss ja noch mal dazu sagen das ist
ja keine politische entscheidung sondern
dem liegt eine auch gesetzlich
festgeschriebene formel zugrunde nach
der errechnet wird man guckt sich die
vertraglich vereinbarten preise an und
dann das was die beschaffer jetzt auf
den spotmärkten sich zu hohen preisen
holen müssen und vorher wurde uns
angekündigt das können eine spanne
zwischen 1,5 und 5 cent je
kilowattstunde seien insofern ist das
einfache mathematik zu sagen das ist er
noch am unteren ende der skala geblieben
wo wir brauchen uns allen nichts
vormachen wir haben eh schon mit enorm
angestiegenen energiepreisen zu tun auch
im gasbereich ganz kommt jetzt noch und
obendrauf wir sind weiterhin gefragt für
ausgleich zu sorgen insbesondere bei
denjenigen die keine rücklagen in
unserer gesellschaft bewirken dietmar
bartsch von der linkspartei sagt die
gasanlage ist ein verarmungsprogramm für
viele menschen bedeutet den sozialen
abstieg für die mehrheit des landes
sehen sie auch so
nein das wäre so wenn man es jetzt
einfach laufen lassen würde wenn dietmar
bartsch ignoriert da ein bisschen aus
parteipolitischem kalkül ja alles was
die bundesregierung eine entlastung
schon gemacht hat und sich auch
vorgenommen hat wenn sie mir erlauben
würde ich da generell gerne einsatz
zudem sagen was wir jetzt auch gerade
aus der linkspartei wir werden jetzt
montagsdemonstration angekündigten man
hofft anscheinend doch noch mal
irgendwann über die fünf prozent hürde
wie darüber zukommen wenn die linke mal
halb so viel energie darauf verwenden
würde sich ernsthaft und kritisch mit
dem verursacher dieser gesamten misere
auseinanderzusetzen mit herrn putin mit
seinem krieg und allen folgen dessen mit
denen wir uns hier politisch
auseinanderzusetzen haben wie man sich
jetzt an der bundesregierung ab arbeitet
dann wäre der gesamtlage viel geholfen
also ich glaube wirklich alle tun gut
daran jetzt kluge vorschläge zu machen
wie wir sinnvoll entlasten aber
irgendwelche vergleiche zur hartz 4
demonstrations- zeiten oder so nein das
ist wirklich nicht angebracht und wir
sind auch nein das ist interessant wird
nun ist aber wir merken es gerade liegen
die nerven blank und ich habe das gefühl
jeder bemüht sich gerade darum dafür zu
sorgen dass der schwarze peter bloß
nicht mit ihm nach hause geht keiner was
ich fand es eben interessant herr kühn
hat das gesagt aber keine politische
entscheidungen also das zustandekommen
des preises der gestern verkündet monate
ist eine politische entscheidung aber
eine gasanlage zu erheben und zwar
innerhalb von sehr kurzer zeit weil man
ein gasversorger ohne paar hat und
feststellte oh der ist wie wir aus der
bankenkrise kennen dieses too big to
fail zu groß um zu scheitern weil er
dann möglicherweise alle mit den abgrund
reißt und dazu sagen wir überlegen das
eine umlage die alle gasverbraucher
trifft das ist eine sehr politische
entscheidung und die koalition die
antwort habe getroffen und wie ich finde
so schnell umgesetzt dass man jetzt mit
diesem mit der frage müssen wir mehr
geld ausgeben das schon denn die frage
der mehrwertsteuer kann ich das in
europa durchsetzen dass die deutschen
das nicht zahlen müssen oder nicht also
was klärt man vorher und wenn man das so
schnell macht und jetzt heute den quasi
die rote karte aus europa kriegt sagte
er er hebt schon eure mehrwertsteuer und
dann gucken wir mal was ihr damit macht
das ist ja politisch
handwerklich mich ganz so sauber
ausgedacht klaus müller hat gelernt mit
dem kopf geschüttelt wir merken uns
warum man mit dem kopf geschüttelt hatte
oder ersetzung gleich erklären aber vor
noch mal die frage an kevin kühn hat wie
kann so etwas passieren handwerklich so
offensichtlich ja
unzulänglich gemacht hat da kann die
mehrwertsteuer gedacht ich meine der
kanzler warf er finanzminister
der hat doch so was auf dem schirm
natürlich ist daran gedacht worden aber
es musste gemeinsame lösung gefunden
werden es ist kein geheimnis es gab
unterschiedliche ideen wie man diese
mehrkosten also dass man sich ja einig
die ist müssen die mehrkosten auf
getreide hat sich außerdem dadurch
gesetzte lampl wer war s das so einfach
ist es tatsächlich nicht das ist ja
einfach unter hohem druck wieder im
moment gearbeitet wird es hätte zum
beispiel auch die möglichkeit gegeben zu
sagen wir machen das aus dem allgemeinen
steueraufkommen
heraus ehrlicherweise müssten wir dafür
aber uns sehr grundsätzlich noch mal in
der koalition in die augen gucken wie
wir das überhaupt mit dem
steueraufkommen handhabe groß ist weil
sie mit der verschuldungsgrenzen
aussieht genau jetzt ist diese lösung
gekommen da sind noch fragen offen und
weil das heute gerade alle mitgekriegt
haben dass diese mehrwertsteuer erhoben
werden muss gehört schon auch dazu dass
der bundeskanzler sich sofort
nach dieser rückmeldung aus brüssel
heute zu wort gemeldet und gesagt hat
die zusätzlichen einnahmen aus der
mehrwertsteuer werden selbstverständlich
in die entlastungs pakete gelenkt und
kommen am ende den menschen kleinen und
mittleren einkommen wieder zugute wir
werden uns nicht mit dem staatshaushalt
daran bereich noch mal wie kann so etwas
passieren handwerklich so ein fehler
also es kommt irgendwann die frage auf
was ist eigentlich mit der
mehrwertsteuer und dann kann man erleben
innerhalb der koalition wie man sich so
gegenseitig sozusagen die schwarzen
peter zuschiebt ich fand bemerkenswert
christian lindner den finanzminister der
auf die frage ob diese mehrwertsteuer
zusätzlich erhoben wird die interessante
formulierung benutzt sowie das
konstruiert ist ja
das war der ellbogencheck gegen robert
habeck direkt gut an der arbeiter
auseinandersetzung mit alice mich jetzt
von dieser stelle hier als sie sind
klassiker dalli na ja wir haben es
einfach generell ein gutes gewiss kein
gutes licht auf die ampel naja da müssen
wir glaube jetzt schon einen halben
schritt weiter zurückgehen der
bundeskanzler hat das ja charmant aber
dann doch deutlich in seiner
sommerpressekonferenz auch gesagt dieses
gesamtsituation die wir jetzt vorfinden
dieser krieg mit seinen auswirkungen die
abhängigkeit bei der gasversorgung von
russland darauf hat es nicht wie man
sich vielleicht hätte wünschen können
langjährige vorkehrungen und annahmen
die regierung jedoch nicht mehr weil er
wie kann sowas handwerklich passieren
dass man sozusagen in der öffentlichkeit
überrascht wird von der frage nein das
war ein land wir sind nicht überrascht
warum sagen das ist der neuwagen klar
dass diese frage dass es dazu
unterschiedliche
rechtsauffassungen gibt deswegen hat
sich der bundesfinanzminister
gewinnen aber wir arbeiten ja unter
hohem druck im moment gerade
gleichzeitig in dem moment wo sie
zurecht und viele menschen einfordern
dass so eine frage geklärt und
beantwortet werden muss gibt es eben
viele unternehmen die beispielsweise gas
anbieten die ebenfalls dringend auf
antworten warten wie ihre mehrkosten ja
die jetzt entstehen durch ausgefallene
lieferungen die sie eigentlich mit
russischen unternehmen vereinbart hatten
wie die ausgeglichen werden auch das
muss schnell beantwortet dass man dabei
keine ton olympiasiege erzielt in
solchen tagen wo man miteinander
versucht das alles auszubalancieren
das liegt der natur der sache wichtig
ist doch am ende das nicht die
gelackmeierten diejenigen sind die jetzt
am ende diese mehrwertsteuer richtung
sondern entlastet werden für sie als
koalition ist wie sie es einmal wieder
da stehen
handwerklich die sache nicht im griff
zumal ja auch die fernwärme frage
zumindest gestern nicht geklärt war es
gibt ja einfach ungeklärte fragen herr
habe gestern in
vertreten musste und es wird ja immer
sehr sehr kritisch der ernsthaft und
sagt das ist jetzt nötig sozusagen
dieses opfer dass wir bringen müssen
springen ja auch nicht alles bringe nur
die gas kunden also die überlegung ob
man nicht vorher bevor man an die bürger
geht die man ja auf der anderen seite
dauernd versucht zu entlasten mit vielen
schritten die koalition unter dem man
doch was vermutet und die man ja auch
argumente nächstes tasche linke tasche
also ich als kunde bekommt 300 euro
energie geld im september von meinem
arbeitgeber überwiesen was
bürokratischen nicht unaufwendig ist
zahl aber dann sozusagen meine hohen
gaspreise die schon jetzt höher sind als
sonst unzahl diese umlage noch mal drauf
und als herren wir mit kunde weiß ich
gar nicht zahle ich das zeigt dass nicht
ich bin jetzt nicht geklärt also die
idee dass wir alle was tun müssen um den
von russland verursachten krieg und die
energie krise abzufedern ist klar aber
die das handwerk dahinter finde ich sehr
zusammengestückelt bin sehr gespannt was
tropical gleich dazu sagt aber er ist
herr müller sie haben einmal schon im
laufe dieser sendung die noch nicht
lange dauert sehr energisch den kopf
geschüttelt warum ist die erste frage
und zweitens wie kann denn sowas
passieren also ich habe jedes
verständnis dieser welt wenn kevin
kühnert sagt okay das passiert alles
gerade unter hohem druck aber der fehler
war ja offensichtlich schon von beginn
an angelegt wenn man sich nochmal diese
sehr interessante formulierung von
christian lindner anschaut der sagt
sowie das konstruiert ist klammer auf
ich habe nichts damit zu tun klammer zu
sowie das konstruiert ist wird das
natürlich eine mehrwertsteuer nach sich
ziehen davon gehe ich einfach mal aus
und genau so ist es passiert wie kann so
etwas sein
vielleicht zuerst zu ihrer ersten frage
ich habe den kopf geschüttelt als frau
münstermann eben gesagt hat wir hätten
juniper gerettet wegen der alten
formulierung too big to fail darum ging
es nicht wir haben ja nicht nur youtube
mit der umlage gerettet sondern alle
importeure russischen gases stehen vor
den ganz gravierenden problemen das sie
für viel geld die differenz menger
nachkaufen müssen aber die nach wie vor
sehr günstigen verträge mit den
stadtwerken haben und insofern ging es
darum diese lieferkette an gas zu retten
zu bewahren eigentlich ist das eine
stadtwerke rettungs oben lage oder auch
eine gasverbraucher rettungs umlage weil
die alternative wäre neben insolvenzen
gewesen gar keine gaslieferung mehr und
das wollen wir uns eben weder für
private haushalte
okay wir haben sommer aber auf keinen
fall für die industrie vorstellen das
war der punkt wo ich den kopf gestellt
habe frau künast hat eben schon darauf
hingewiesen unter welchen hohen druck
tatsächlich juni per rettung über die
bühne gehen musste der konzern hat eine
gewinnwarnung herausgegeben
er stand unter dem druck der
ratingagenturen die bundesregierung hat
verhandelt um das beste für die
steuerzahler rauszuholen also ich will
daran erinnern dass die bundesregierung
schon mit milliarden euro eingegangen
bei der rettung von juniper aber
gleichzeitig brauchen die gasimporteure
natürlich ein geschäftsmodell mit dem
sie weiter existieren können sie müssen
gas einkaufen und verkaufen dabei dürfen
sie kein defizit machen millionenschwere
jeden tag und darum war es leider
notwendig darum auch meine formulierung
zu den gaspreisen leider notwendig die
gaspreise so anzufassen wie das jetzt
mit der umlage geschehen ist es gab noch
eine alternative man hätte nur die
gaskunden der betroffene importeure mit
den höheren preisen belasten können aber
ich glaube dass wir die noch schlechter
variante gewesen darum der weg unter
hohem zeitdruck ich glaube am ende ist
wichtig was bei den menschen ankommt ist
es noch ein wenig hin bis in rechnung
gestellt wird und bis dahin kann man die
probleme die es gibt mit denen die
bundesregierung offen umgeht noch
korrigieren sie selber sagen des
gesetzes sehr schnell geschrieben worden
es wird wahrscheinlich nachjustierungen
geben welche
das sind die dinge die sie gerade schon
diskutiert haben also wenn man innerhalb
dieses gesetzes keine regelung für die
mehrwertsteuer findet minister habeck
und so habe ich auch und das kann so
scholz und finanzminister lindner
verstanden einen anderen weg geben diese
mehreinnahmen man die menschen wo
möglichst sozial ausgewogen
zurückzugeben auch die anderen beiden
punkte hat fraumünster man ja richtig
beschrieben weder für die fernwärme
kunden noch für die festpreis kunden gab
es jetzt eine sichere regelung die in
dem gesetz in der ersten gesetzesnovelle
oder letzten gesetzesnovelle drin
beschlossen wurden ich gehe davon aus
das wird jetzt im kabinett beraten weil
der erklärte wille ist ja die gaspreis
steigung auf so viele gaskunden wie
möglich zu verteilen und dabei wird die
bundesregierung und am ende hat sich der
bundestag beraten und ich gehe davon aus
rechtzeitig eine gute lösung finden
kapitel legt die stirn sorgen voll
entfalten was geht ihnen also ökonomie
durch den kopf wenn sie sehen was da
gerade passiert
also was mir jetzt die stirn in falten
gelegt hat das war eigentlich dass ich
denke die diskussion um die
mehrwertsteuer ist wichtig dass man
diskutiert ist das ein fehler ist kein
fehler es ist geld aber es ist im
verhältnis zu den gesamten mehrkosten
die auf die haushalte zukommen seine
ehrlichen tropfen auf den heißen stein
das sind bei der umlage pro
kilowattstunde 0,4
prozent ungeschehen moment sieht so aus
als ob also ein bisschen kollege von mir
hat jetzt die mahnung oder die rechnung
bekommen das er 25 cent pro
kilowattstunde in zukunft zahlt waren
früher ungefähr 7 das heißt da sind wir
bei rechnung 18 sie sind ist strom nein
ich bin bei meinen ganzen 18 cent mehr
das ist das ist wirklich die große frage
diese 0,4 da kann man sich darüber
aufregen weil ja möglicherweise
technischer fehler war ich hab das
gefühl dass dominiert die durst
diskussion momentan in einer art und
weise die einfach nicht mehr angemessen
das ist das eine das zweite ist ist ja
auch die frage hätte man diese gas
umlage hätte man es anders gestalten
können die eine option wäre auf jeden
fall gewesen dass man sagt man
finanziert aus allgemeinen steuermitteln
hat man im prinzip ja gerade bei der
eeg-umlage gemacht dass man sagt das ist
im prinzip eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
aufgabe
das wird aus steuermitteln finanziert
aber da muss man ehrlich genug sein dass
man dann auch sagt irgendwo muss das
geld herkommen da müssen wir anders die
steuern erhoben werden also ich glaube
das ist schon eine diskussion die wald
führen kann ist das so gerecht dass es
nur die gaskunden oder profitieren wir
alle von einem gesunden gas system die
kehrseite der medaille wenn ich sage
sind nur die gaskunden da kann man sich
natürlich auch überlegen wenn ich jetzt
pech habe und mein unternehmen hat nicht
bis zum ersten mai bereits einen solchen
vertrag mit einem russischen importe
gehabt sondern hat mit einem anderen
importeur hat nach dem ersten mai einen
vertrag über lieferungen geschlossen
dann kriegt es diese ausgleich nicht
korrigieren sie mich wenn ich falsch
liege das heißt also was ich tatsächlich
beobachte sind massives
auseinanderdriften auch der gas
haushalts gaspreise und das wird eben
durch die umlage nicht gemindert das
muss der der wenig zeit trägt ist die
reiche oben drauf wie der mit den 25
cent weg sagt er bekommt personen
interessant das sind die eigentlich
wesentlich müller nicht glücklich weil
titel gefeiert korrigieren sie mich wenn
sie was falsches ist soja
kapitel hat das vollkommen richtig
beschrieben allerdings sind auch die
gasimporteure die eben das problem haben
durch die kürzung von nord stream 1
diejenigen die bisher gas ausrüstern
imponieren haben die haben sozusagen die
differenz jetzt zu finanzieren aus dem
bisherigen gasverträgen aus russland in
eher günstig den hohen spotmarkt preisen
die sie jetzt obendrauf finanzieren
müssen darum hat sich die
bundesregierung für ein passgenaues
rettungssystem an der stelle entschieden
sie korrigiert nicht alle probleme es
gibt und frau titel hat auch recht die
gaspreis steigung die wir markt
getrieben sehen durch die
spotmarktpreise sind um ein vielfaches
gravierender und so höher als die umlage
und der ist recht als die komponente der
mehrwertsteuer aber nichts davon sich
doch fragen warum wie sie es gesagt
haben so diese allgemeinen steuermitteln
nicht ins spiel kamen also oder über
gewinn steuer ich weiß da ist ja die spd
herr klingbeil der spd-vorsitzende auch
sehr daran interessiert
herr linder wert das total ab aber ich
glaube diese um diese diskussion wird
die koalition auf keinen fall
herumkommen die frage nach der
schuldengrenze begrenzung nächsten jahr
soll sie wieder gelten oder nicht wird
man auch nicht drum herum kommen also
wenn die steigerungen die wir uns ja
jetzt doch das ist auf dem papier was
heißt das schon diese umlage wenn das
aber im briefkasten liegt dann ist
dieser krieg wirklich und die
auswirkungen angekommen ich glaube die
diskussion ist dann nicht mehr
theoretisch um ein paar cent mehr
mehrwertsteuer oder nicht sondern die
ist sehr sehr real und da werden die
entlastung die es bisher gibt nicht
reichen frau titel hat ja auch recht
wollte sozusagen nicht 1 den ersten
schritt vor dem zweiten machen weil den
zweiten schritt in den haben wir auch
tatsächlich uns mal genauer angesehen in
der vorbereitung für die sendung es geht
natürlich nicht nur diese mehrwertsteuer
wenn man sich mal anschaut was eine vier
bis fünfköpfige familie im august 2021
noch für gas bezahlt hat und wann das
ungefähr
1250 euro pro jahr ein jahr später waren
es 3500
68 euro das heißt eine signifikante
steigerung und da ist die gasanlage noch
gar nicht drin und es gibt schon
preissteigerungen die darüber
hinausgehen also das ist nur eines ende
der veranstalter so dient die
3568 euro august 22 versus august 2021
es um sich ein anstieg von sechs bis
sieben cent auf ungefähr 17 cent pro
kilowattstunde und wie gesagt ein
kollege hat ja schon 25 cent ins haus
geflattert bekommen das heißt also das
kann durchaus noch höher werden und das
ist eben das ist das massive problem
über das man eigentlich reden muss wie
bekommt man das tatsächlich hin dass
eben auch ärmere haushalte das ist jetzt
ein ziemlich hoher verbrauch muss man
auch sagen das ist ziemlich großes hause
also habe ich das spiel gemeinsam vier
bis fünfköpfige familie 20.000 km das
ist schon eine ganze menge
durchschnitt ist glaube ich das team
aber die das beispiel ist das ist sehr
exemplarisch und und sehr krass von 1200
euro hoch auf 35 und mitgas umlage
landest du dann bei über
4100 euro das ist ja überlegt das ist
paar leute gibt die noch das ist die
wahre zahl über die wir spielen schnitt
aber nun gar nichts zu sagen es gibt
tatsächlich menschen die haben alle
verträge die sind weit runter und es
gibt menschen die haben neue verträge
die sind weit drüber und da sieht man
dann auch das spektrum das ist ja völlig
unabhängig davon ob ich jetzt arm oder
reich binden es kommt einfach darauf an
was ich für einen gasvertrag vielleicht
geschlossen habe in der hoffnung es wird
günstiger oder in dem vertrauen ist
bleibt zu teuer also dass das ist sehr
erotisch hoher verbrauch sagen sie war
nochmal von 1200 euro
4200 euro binnen eines jahres mit gas
umlage ja aber jetzt was machen wir
damit was ist das für ein sozialer
sprengstoff der sich darin versteckt
natürlich liegt da ein solches potenzial
drin das ist ja nicht neu und deswegen
wird ja seit wochen und monaten um die
richtigen entlastung rom manches ist auf
dem weg anderes wird kommen lassen sie
uns nicht erstarren vor diesen zahlen
die sind kraft da brauchen wir überhaupt
nicht drüber diskutieren aber der
großteil dieser zahlen ist durch die
marktsituation aufgrund der allgemeinen
umstände die bekannt sind getrieben
daran werden wir jetzt kurzfristig
politisch nicht mehr verändern können
man kann an der umlage da hätte man
jetzt mitdiskutieren können hätten macht
man das anders aber der großteil dieses
preises kommt dadurch zustande dass
anbieter zum teil an den spotmärkten
gerade das zehnfache dessen zahlen wofür
sie sich ursprünglich gas beschafft
hatten die entscheidende frage ist also
die der entlastungen und der
zielgenauigkeit von entlastungen sie
wissen 30 milliarden sind ja bereits
unterwegs manchen star die 300 euro
energiepreis pauschale kommt mit dem
september gehalt bei allen die dann ein
beschäftigungsverhältnis sind und jetzt
laufen in diesen tagen und wie ich hoffe
mit einem baldigen abschluss der
gespräche in der koalition die
verhandlungen darüber was die nächsten
schritte gemeinhin wird jetzt von
dritten paket gesprochen wie das
aussieht darin werden sachen zum thema
einkommenssteuer enthalten sein wie
genau dass es gegenstand der politischen
debatte in der koalition noch aber
natürlich wird zum thema einkommensteuer
was passieren wir sind aus meiner sicht
aus sicht der spd in der schuld bei
rentnerinnen und rentnern aber gerade
auch noch mal bei studierenden die in
vielen fällen moment noch vor offenen
fragen stehen und wir müssen ganz klar
uns den kleinen und mittleren
einkommensgruppen schwerpunktmäßig zu
wenden braucht man sich um mittlere
einkommensgruppen konkret naja ich weiß
es dann immer total interessant auf
einzelne eckzahlen abzuziehen zur
wahrheit gehört natürlich auch das leben
das in unterschiedlichen ecken des
landes unterschiedlich teuer also ein
haushaltseinkommen von vier oder fünf
1000 euro brutto heißt in münchen was
anderes als interner oder so das muss
man sich auch vor augen führen mir ist
wichtig für die spd für die kann ich an
der stelle nur sprechen zu sagen uns
geht es hier nicht darum jetzt nur auf
menschen im transfer leistungsbezug oder
die vielleicht mindestlohn bekommen
zuschauen sondern natürlich haben auch
hausslers single haushalte mit
zweieinhalb oder 3000 euro paare die mit
456 1000 euro im monat nach hause gehen
sie leben hier nicht wie gott in
frankreich in so einer situation wo die
zahlen diese lesen gerade eintreten die
haben auch einen entlastungsbetrag das
muss man immer ins verhältnis setzen
schauen sie in den osten beispielsweise
da haben die menschen aus historischen
gründen weit überdurchschnittlich keine
rücklagen keine vermögenswerte das ist
wiederum auch anders zu betrachten die
können solche vorauszahlungen die sie
jetzt manchmal verschickt werden einfach
nicht leisten greifen einem nackten mann
die tasche wir werden also ein bisschen
aus steuern müssen aber wir gucken hier
nicht nur auf menschen die jetzt zuletzt
gerade bei der tafel angestanden ist
auch ein riesiges drama sondern wir
sprechen über weite teile der
gesellschaft die in einer situation sind
wo sie ist absolut verdient finanzielle
unterstützung politisch auf den weg
gebracht das heißt die frau münster und
lächelt süffisant ja ich frage mich auch
herr lindner das auch
wenn ich mir sein letztes interview an
geschaut habe war er sehr dezidiert in
seiner aussage das eigentlich jetzt
nicht mehr so viel geht und dass er an
seiner politischen überzeugung der
schuldenbremse und so weiter festhalten
will er hat einen vorschlag zum
inflationsausgleich gemacht wie übrigens
ja der finanzminister vor im urlaub
stolz dass auch schon zwei mal gemacht
hat scholz hat in seiner apk in seiner
sommer pk eigentlich auch gesagt ja er
findet das ganz gut was ein
finanzminister so sagt kann ja nicht
falsch sein ich übersetze mal
so wie ich das empfunden habe spricht
eigentlich ist ja die achse lindner
scholz gerade gar nicht so schlecht und
ich bin gespannt wie die spd und auch
die grünen da reingehen wollen
konstruktiv das kann ich sagen
damit wir uns nicht missverstehen an der
stelle und auf scholz hat das gesagt was
die reine parteispitze der spd auch
gesagt haben wir finden es erstmal gut
dass wir über entlastungen gesprochen
wird auch im bereich der
einkommenssteuer da haben wir das ding
habe ich das gerade noch mal ausgeführt
überhaupt nicht dagegen das ist gut dass
hier in einem volumen von 10 milliarden
euro und man muss fairerweise sagen es
sind nicht nur zehn milliarden des
finanzministers im bund sondern da ist
auch geld der länder mit drin denn die
einkommenssteuer verteilt sich
schlussendlich auch dass wir über so
eine größenordnung jetzt über die genaue
aufteilung auf die verschiedenen
einkommensgruppen darüber sprechen wir
jetzt allerdings noch politisch in der
regierung denn das in euro und cent denn
das ist ja entscheidend für haushalte
man bezahlt ja nicht mit prozenten an
der supermarktkasse sondern mit zeit mit
euro und cent denn das da je höher das
einkommen ist mehr rauskommt und bei
denen wo keine rücklagen sind und auch
am ende des monats wenig einkommen aufs
konto kommt dass dort zum teil dann bei
einem single haushalt mit 20.000 im jahr
nur 100 ein paar zerquetschte rauskommen
das kann noch nicht der weisheit letzter
schluss sein und da werden wir uns
sicherlich politisch noch mal über
andere zahlen darüber beugen müssten bis
zu welchem einkommen sollte das denn
gehen mit der entlastung das will ich
jetzt nicht aus der hohlen hand
verantworten nicht weil ich mich drücken
will aber wie gesagt wir haben es
wirklich regional mit sehr
unterschiedlicher station dollar ersatz
bezahlt sollte der auch entlastet werden
naja der wird in dem moment wo wir beim
einkommensteuertarif was machen alleine
auch durch die anpassung beim freibetrag
haben wir ja dieses jahr rückwirkend
schon gemacht und wird jetzt noch mal
weitergehen natürlich kommt da
automatisch auch bei einkommen wie sie
hier in dieser diskussionsrunde
versammelt sind etwas an um so wichtiger
dass wir eben gleichzeitig auch über
direktzahlungen beispielsweise sprechen
wer keine einkommenssteuer zahlt wird
über jegliche verschiebung des
einkommensteuertarifs nicht entlastet
das sind die leute die erreichen wir
indem wir für ihre kinder wie in der
vergangenheit gezielt geld auszahlen das
sind die leute die auch mit einem
minijob wo sie am ende des jahres keine
einkommenssteuer entrichtet haben dann
die 300 euro energiepreis pauschale
bekommen das sind gelder und zuwendungen
die ganz exakt bei den leuten ankommen
diese treffen sollen ohne dass sie ich
sie beide und herr müller auch noch geld
auf den großen haufen oben drauf
geworfen bekommt darum muss ist die
ansage von scholz you will never walk
alone du wirst nie allein sein das sagt
er jetzt bei jeder
bei jeder gelegenheit ist ja sehr hoch
in dieser krise das heißt ja wir lassen
dich nicht allein und was wäre die
alternative
na ja
es gab den bonus in der korona krise des
staatlichen geldes es gibt jetzt die
dieses versprechen aber es muss irgendwo
herkommen und die frage die hat mir
bisher noch keiner beantwortet weder
herr linder und harbeck noch erzeugt wer
beides gehört natürlich zusammen wenn
wir in der koalition darüber sprechen
welches geld wir noch zur entlastung
jetzt weiter mobilisieren
dann steht spiegelbildlich dem die frage
entgegen oder welche haushaltsmittel
stehen und sowohl der finanzminister hat
ja auch rücklagen hatte er signalisiert
im haushalt aber ab einem gewissen
volumen von entlastung wird man
gegebenenfalls dann auch sagen müssen
ist das alles noch über einzubringen mit
einem auslaufen der ausnahme von der
schuldenregel so wie es vorgesehen war
für den jahreswechsel 22 23 oder und und
geht das ohne dass wir an irgendeiner
steuerschraube drehen und sie haben es
angesprochen vorhin in meiner partei zum
teil auch bei den grünen gibt es große
sympathien für einen über gewinnsteuer
wie sie auch andere europäische
staaten also eu mitgliedstaaten bereits
eingeführt haben um krisen profiteure
die man durchaus sehr konkret auch
abgrenzen kann von unternehmen die
einfach mit gesehen wurde sie sind für
die über gewinn steuer heute ist gerade
eine studie rausgekommen dass alleine im
bereich der energiewirtschaft wie es mit
unternehmen zu tun haben die
voraussichtlich in einem dreistelligen
milliardenbereich allein im ersten
halbjahr
2022 zusätzliche gewinne erwirtschaftet
haben und wenn wir jetzt in den letzten
also gestern und am wochenende haben mit
großer geste shell und rwe uns
mitgeteilt dass sie darauf verzichten
sich die gasanlage auch auszahlen zu
lassen viele haben sich dann dafür
bedankt ich darf ja ich appelliere dafür
dass wir ein bisschen die selbstachtung
auch als gesellschaft behalten und
denjenigen die mit anderen energie
sparen wo sie beispielsweise im bereich
der erneuerbaren oder auch im bereich
des atomstroms gerade bis zu 50%
gewinnmargen steigerungen haben die
dadurch richtig reich werden wo riesige
dividenden ausgeschüttet werden ja
natürlich verzichten die dann darauf
diese umlage sicher starten zu lassen
und wollen damit vielleicht auch ein
bisschen debatte über die über wir waren
nicht so ärgern würden sie sind sie
führen über gewinnsteuern ja ihr kanzler
ist dagegen nein er hat darauf
hingewiesen dass das nicht im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart ist dass er
nicht richtig aber 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr waren auch nicht im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart also wir
haben uns darauf geeinigt dass zu machen
ganz kurz vor ort über gewinn steuer ist
olaf scholz für die über gewinn steuer
zu haben oder nicht ich verstehe ihn so
dass er dafür zu haben ist wir müssen
ihn selbst fragen natürlich
wir haben keinen beschluss dazu gefasst
sie sehen sein generalsekretär sie
wissen sie ja ungefähr ja alle in der
spd äußern uns ja seit tagen und wochen
dazu befürworten nicht nur mein
parteivorsitzender nicht nur meine
parteivorsitzende es ist das spd
regierte bundesland bremen gewesen die
er im bundesrat einen antrag für aber
gar nicht letztendlich ganz erreicht
haben spd regierte länder haben im
bundesrat zugestimmt die anderen haben
dagegen gestimmt das ist jetzt nicht so
dass ich ihre frage scheitern wir raten
selbst gehören als auch mal ganz kurz
war im zusammenhang mit dem
entlastungspaket wird immer wieder auch
diskutiert steuern zu erhöhen etwa eine
über gewinn steuer einzuführen war auch
eine erhöhung der einkommensteuersätze
für die besonders gut verdienenden
menschen kann das teil des
entlastungspaket es sein wir haben uns
darauf verständigt keine solche
einkommensteuer erhöhung zu machen für
spitzenverdiener
das stand im spd-wahlprogramm ich glaube
auch in dem der grünen aber nicht in
allen dreien das
ist auch etwas was sich dort nicht
findet und das ganz klar zu sagen
technisch übrigens auch sehr
herausfordernd aber deshalb
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt im
augenblick auf das was wir tun sollen
zur entlastung der bürgerinnen und
bürgern also wenn ein ehemaliger
finanzminister ein ausgefuchster
finanzmarktes das technisch
herausfordern dann klingt das nicht so
als würde in den nächsten drei wochen
diese
steuer umsetzen wollen bei allem respekt
mir ist zu viel
das sieht nicht wenn dieser diskussion
drin wir können haben wir ihnen werden
die gerade rausgehalten dass er dafür
ist der bundeskanzler ist in dieser
nicht ganz einfachen koalition in einer
krise die nicht angelegt waren
koalitionsvertrag dafür zuständig den
laden zusammenzuhalten es gibt ja genug
andere die die bühne suchen und sich mit
eigenen vorschlägen nehmen er ist der
oberste gralshüter dieses
koalitionsvertrages denn er hat das
alles zusammen geschmiedet und er hat
eben mit diesem wort dort was er
verwendet hat das nimmt ja bezug auf den
koalitionsvertrag sachgerecht
wiedergegeben dass in diesem
koalitionsvertrag das nicht drin steht
er hat aber auch das wort hat er im
augenblick gesagt oder momentan eher
gesagt ist das nicht geplant dass wir
das machen diese aufgabe aussage und das
zeichnet dann einen erfahrenen
regierungspolitiker auslässt alles
weitere offen und das ist auch richtig
so denn politische einigung werden nicht
in der sommerpressekonferenz sehr
interessantes gefunden sondern indem die
koalitionspartner vertraulicher im sand
sitzen und sich die karten liegt